you know allah always have better parent
than we have
tomorrow tomorrow god have plan
inshallah doesn't matter what's gonna
happen
i'm gonna go keep forward keep going and
make history inshallah thank you so much
nobody take this title before is with
muslim muslims like more than billion
people you know
when come ramadan this is everything for
me i don't think about fight because i
believe in one god this is my religion
religion for me number one sport is not
for me number one
for all the khabib nurmagomedov fans
this is a denizen of the russian
republic of dagestan for all the mma
fans he's an undefeated mma fighter
and i'm going to go ahead and discuss
some peculiar idiosyncrasies you've seen
him do it some things he's done some
things he said
during some of his fights
so you can appreciate i'm sure you will
appreciate when you can connect it to
something you're familiar with the
winner by submission you know kimura
[Music]
now let's start off with what he's doing
here this is not just particular to him
you'll see many people who want to keep
it humble and who are thankful and
grateful they point up
pointing up to the one up above up above
the creation up above the heavens in the
universe the one who created this whole
universe the galaxies the seven seas
everything in this world
isn't he not worthy of all praise and
things and that's what he's doing
because
people become very arrogant and this is
something we have to be very very
careful of and we can all take a lesson
from this to keep it humble
to keep it humble you cannot go wrong
with keeping it humble arrogance will
get you lost
we'll lose your friends who likes to be
around arrogant people
and at the end
failure failure at the end
[Music]
why is he putting his face on the ground
what's he doing kissing the ground
but let me connect it because the point
was if i can if we can connect it to
something that you are familiar with
someone who you're familiar with
you're probably going to appreciate it a
lot more you might even start doing it
and
if something works if it's going to
help improve your life
why not give it a try
and check this out you know jesus we
know jesus i mean did you know muslims
love jesus there's this fighter
here if anyone knows who he is he's
wearing uh he's another mixed martial
arts fighter he's got a he's got a shirt
on
talking about how muslims love jesus did
you know that so if you're a
khabib fan you've learned something
already
and you'll see that muslims they have a
deep reverence and love for jesus as a
mighty messenger who was sent
just like abraham knowing all the other
messengers calling people to connect
with the one who gave us these abilities
these gifts in life
like khabib was given some very talented
athlete
and and he's acknowledging that this is
from the creator and now again he's
taking it a step further and just like
jesus and related to someone you know
jesus in the gospel of matthew 26 39 it
says that he went and he went a little
further and he fell on his face
and prayed to god
isn't that amazing this is something
that habib doing not only him but
muslims 1.7 billion human beings and
muslim is simply one who surrenders who
submits himself not to a man
not to a woman not to money not to fame
not to anything
or anyone but to the creator up above
isn't that beautiful do you learn
something already he's doing what all
the prophets of god did
so it shouldn't be next time you see him
do that next time you're a fan of khabib
and you see you see him fighting at the
end and if he wins god willing and he
prostrate he puts his head on the floor
you can connect it now you watch this
you say oh he's doing what jesus did
he's giving praise and thanks keeping it
humble
excuse me guys alhamdulillah now let's
move on to the next thing what he said
he says some some words now sometimes
when we hear something in another
language we can't appreciate it excuse
me guys
alhamdulillah i want to say something he
says alhamdulillah
[Applause]
what does that mean why is he saying
something
in another language in arabic now i want
to connect this again back
to the one i'm sure many christians who
love jesus people who aren't even maybe
christian but they heard jesus they have
they have a connection to him do you
know that jesus he called on the creator
if you ever watched the passion of
christ
[Music]
in arabic it's just allah this is the
creator we're talking about
and he is saying alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
everything god gave me
so again he's keeping it humble if
anything we could take away from this
video is is is that quality of keeping
it humble we got too much we're all
susceptible to it ego
the ego can take over and you become
very arrogant who likes to be around
arrogant people keeping it humble again
he's saying alhamdulillah it's just like
saying thank you god
everything god gave me very simple now
you're going to preach can you
appreciate that let's go on to the next
thing
and the last but not the least
allahu akbar do you hear him saying it
what does it mean is this some war cried
jihad they're coming to get us how
ridiculous does that sound but that's
what some people think
do you know that
over
60 000 books in a span of a hundred
years have been written against islam
according to
the times magazine article published in
1979 april 16th i believe it was
and that the islamophobia industry is a
250 million dollar annual business
so you know probably the information you
got
the book you read
false propaganda fear-mongering
and the hate mongers they're making
money bashing throwing dirt on islam so
allahu akbar is not a war cry
it's simply allah god is greater greater
than that money that dollar that job
that woman
everything that you can imagine god
almighty the creator allah is greater
than this and again going back to
keeping it humble
always thanking
the one who gave you the abilities to
win that championship
to get up in the morning
to eat the wonderful food to breathe
this air you don't got to go to walmart
to get it it's free
so you say god almighty is great it's
like saying hallelujah hallelujah you've
heard that allah
allahu akbar god almighty is the
greatest
so that's what khabib is saying i'll
help you to
familiarize yourself with some of the
things that he does what muslims do in
general because khabib is a muslim one
who has consciously submitted to the
creator of the heavens and earth
and some of those stereotypes that one
might have in the back of his head he's
heard this term allahu akbar now if you
were to equate because islam is a
beautiful way of life calling you have
peace
with the creator peace within yourself
so you can have that peace that money
can't buy and you have peace with
humanity if you were to take all the
isis and the boko haram and al-qaeda
which
which didn't even exist a decade ago
it's because all of these wars is that
hate
war hate violence terrorism cycle that
we got to stop innocent blood here there
everywhere is human life we got to
condemn one condemn all and when you
have any large group of people you're
going to have radicals you're going to
have extremists but we also have to see
what's the root of all this and islam is
not the root my friends
no islam brings that peace
and happiness into one's life and when
someone has peace and happiness he's not
trying to blow nobody up especially
himself or innocent people
but you have these things going on but
this is a geopolitical thing and if you
were to add up all of these groups this
is just a side note i'm going out for
natanzha isis boko haram and all these
groups i'm sure you've heard and people
out there associate because some people
are going to watch this video they're
going to think you know again those
those because of the effect of the
islamophobia machine so take all these
radical groups
compare that to the over 1.7 billion
muslims all over the globe
it would only equate to if you have this
small fringe element to the 1.7 billion
last time i checked it would be like
0.006
it's like taking the kkk lowers the
resistance army or some of these these
secular atheists grooves pkk
and all all the taimou tigers all of
these these these these terrorist groups
and now you try to
pump them up
put them up as if they're exemplary
representatives of christianity
of secularism of atheism whatever ism
that wouldn't be fair there wouldn't be
rights you can't take a radical fringe
element and try to pump them up as if
they represent islam they don't they
don't represent habib they don't
represent me they don't represent the
over 1.7 billion muslims who again
are trying to keep it humble keep it
simple live a peaceful life
like everyone else people who have
connected with muslims john dutcher will
straight out tell you what he thought of
muslims i
actually
hated muslims the women with their
headdress on you know i just would sneer
at them dutcher was surrounded by the
people he loathed but muslims moving in
moved him it took this to
yeah to wake me you know wake me up yeah
a change of heart for the man who didn't
realize he had such a big heart
you know
what struck me the most honestly was
when i took a minute to actually talk
to some of the muslim people to find out
you know they are just like me and i am
uneducated on their religion
you know i could easily make as many
mistake judgment calls as any other
person out there
but when i took a second to sit down and
listen to them
and um
actually enter their mosque and go in
and watch some of their prayers it was a
beautiful thing and they answered some
of my questions that i had
and i just feel that maybe that that's
something that they they should do too
for the people a lot a lot of us are
uneducated you know educate us on your
religion let us know that not
everybody's a bad bad person he said i
am very glad
to see you here thank you for being here
this is america
and i just want to say as a christian to
all my muslim brothers and sisters
that we are glad to have you
we are you are our neighbors we stand
with you we will resist any attempts to
hurt you
and please reach out to us we will reach
out to you thank you very much have made
the human connection they've seen past
all the fear-mongering and all the hype
and now
that's it we're going to curtail it one
more i got a bonus for you what's he
doing in the back here what's he doing
in the back some people might see this
picture and there's a there's a black
house or cube this is
[Applause]
killers khabib like many muslims make
this journey once in a lifetime if
you're physically and financially able
it's the first house of worship get this
built by abraham to commemorate the
worship of the one god remember islam is
based on five pillars where anyone can
be a muslim
habib todd berger came here from the u.s
of jewish ancestry raised a christian he
converted islam two years ago
all pilgrims here wear the simple white
ichram and all markers of social status
disappear so my family has concerns and
issues
and they also
recognize that i have a deep connection
with
god with the one god i believe that
people have no idea what islam is
originally from texas habib now lives in
california he says his biggest challenge
is to change misconceptions in america
about islam
it's
it's unfortunate that
the media in the states has portrayed
islam as it is
because there's no connection between
terrorism and islam as arafat day draws
to an end
many like habib continue their prayers
in the spot where muslims say prophet
muhammad delivered his last sermon
the other four pillars if you didn't
know are to testify what's in your very
nature it's natural to believe in the
creator they've done scientific studies
of the god spot and all of us
at oxford university not too long ago
they did a study and they concluded that
the belief in a creator is intrinsic
it's innate it's built in all of us this
belief is something acquired
so you do something that is natural
that's within your capability that you
give birth to what's already inside you
that there's nothing worthy of worship
nothing in the creation except the one
who created the creation the one god the
creator and muhammad is the last and
final messenger this will automatically
include not exclude
every messenger that came before him
with the same message submits your will
to god almighty allah
that is the first pillar second is to
establish the prayer five times a day
minimum
not because god needs it because we need
it we need a recharge of the heart to
keep it humble otherwise we get
we get taken away by this temporal world
and we don't
remember we forget that this life is a
test and we got to prepare
ourselves
for the day of judgment and we're going
to be judged and evaluated just like in
high school college there's an
evaluation this life is at and those
five pillars help us
to remain cognizant of our purpose in
life and the third is giving in charity
to the poor zakat fasting during the
month of ramadan and this is something
jesus did all the messengers of god did
they were all muslims ones who submit to
the will of god khabib is a muslim one
who submits to god you could be a muslim
anyone could be a muslim anytime this is
what a muslim is
and it was our humble attempt to
familiarize you with some of the things
that this mma fighter does so next time
you see him you watch him you can
appreciate them it's not something
something that
is foreign to you now strange we've
connected it to things that you can
relate to
and if you want to know more call us
1-800-662-islam and
reach out connect visit the muslims you
know there's a lot of misinformation out
there i quoted you from time magazine
all of these these
books that have been published the the
industry are bashing islam but we need
to connect
as humans connect as humanity so we can
work to make the world a better place
and we're not going to do it through
fear and fear mongering we're not going
to do it through this hate hate breeds
hate we need this is that that the
educational process that will help solve
these problems the human connection is
another main factor
we're doing our small little part
and i hope that you can tune in with us
every week to the dean show where we
help clear this many of these
misconceptions and to our brother
habib
god willing this gets to him we can like
to have you been out this show that show
aerial hawaii show you can make it
inshallah with your brother
on the dean's show i have my people
reach out to your people and inshallah
god willing we can make the connections
and we can get to meet and have you on
the program thank you very much
everybody tuning in we'll see you next
time same time same channel here on the
dean show
like this video subscribe if you haven't
already
peace be with you salaam